man: Ladies and gentlemen,
good morning.
Please welcome Steven
from the Lego company.
[applause]
Canvin: Hey.
Good morning, everybody.
How are you?
It's gonna be
a great day today.
I just want to tell you,
I've been given 10 minutes
to actually
do a little presentation
just before the keynote starts.
So in ten minutes
all the excitement will start,
but I'll show you
a couple things here.
I just want to tell you
about how we from Lego
have embraced
developers out there.
But some of you found
the bricks on your seats,
and I just have a little
question for you, which is,
so how many
different combinations
do you think you can actually
put these bricks together?
And please do not Google that.
That would be cheating.
You might get the answer before
the end of the presentation.
So we at Lego,
we have a big mission,
which is to inspire and develop
the builders of tomorrow.
We want to create
and make children
become greater thinkers
and problem solvers
and prepare them for the future
and the challenges out there.
We also make products
for children of all ages.
And also we've seen
how people out there
have expanded our products
and taken it
beyond its boundaries,
and most of all, with the
Lego MindStorms robotic toolkit,
which came out in 1998.
We made a robotic toolkit
that was prepared for children
from age 12 and up
with proprietary software,
customized hardware,
and software to boot,
but apparently this product
also appealed to adults.
So within the first five months
after we launched
back in 1998,
our product got hacked.
The hardware--
our proprietary hardware
and software got hacked.
The components,
all our vital components
were put in a shopping list
on the internet.
Our legal department
was freaking out.
And they wanted to take action.
They wanted
to take these people down
and stop them right there.
Well, we said,
"Let's see what happens."
And actually,
this was not harmful.
It actually, expanded--
It actually started
the community around it
of the adult fans out there.
So actually
we learned some lessons
that when we in 2004
wanted to introduce
a new generation
of Lego MindStorms,
which we launched in 2006,
we said, "Let's embrace
all these developers out there,
because they will
hack our products anyway."
That's one of the lessons
we learned.
They will take our pieces apart.
So let's see what we can do and
actually take these people in.
And also, another
important lesson is
that these guys knew more
about our product than we did.
I certainly believe that.
So how do you go about actually
finding these fans out there
who actually know more about--
these developers
that we need to bring in?
Well, as I said,
there was a community
that had developed and formed
around Lego MindStorms,
which was quite a first
for Lego.
And as you can see,
we call adult fans AFOLs--
Adult Fans Of Lego.
Well, it's actually a name
they made up themselves,
but we adapted to that,
and we work with these guys,
and I find that
they're really, really strong
when it comes
to Lego MindStorms products.
So, back in 2004,
we actually opened up
a little work forum,
closed work forum.
Invited four people in.
Which we called--
we called the forum
MindStorms User Panel,
hence the name "the Muppets."
It was their own nickname.
They came up with it again.
But what we did was,
we invited these people in,
into our holiest of places,
into our R&D.
You wouldn't normally have
people invited into your R&D
just coming from the outside.
Of course
they signed the agreement,
but we took a calculated risk.
This time we did not ask
the lawyers for permission,
because we found
it would be better
to actually ask for forgiveness.
[laughs]
[applause]
Thank you.
So as you can see
in this picture,
we have,
on the left side here,
Steve and David
talking to our designers,
sorting out elements.
They actually came up
with new elements
that we hadn't thought about.
They actually suggested
an ultra-sonic sensor
that we hadn't thought about,
because some of the old--
in the old generation,
some of the fans
had actually hacked
and made their own sensors,
right?
So also today,
what we see is a great amount
of software applications
that has been made,
because we said,
"Let's go open-source
with all this.
Let's open up
to the community."
So today, on our website,
you can find
a software developer kit,
a firmware developer kit,
a hardware developer kit,
and a Bluetooth developer kit,
all for the sake of
proliferating our products.
And it's the fans who have
actually born our whole product
as it is today.
As you can see,
with all the names
of all these different
software applications,
there are no
limits and boundaries
to what you
can actually do with this.
So if any of you guys
out there
actually have played
with Lego MindStorms
or have helped
expand our products,
I salute you and thank you.
Keep pushing.
We definitely appreciate that.
But also, of course,
on the model sides,
I could talk for hours
about the thousands
and thousands
of inventions that fans
have made out there.
Of all ages.
I guess we're all
children inside.
Especially that's what
we believe at Lego.
As you can see,
getting a robot
to solve a Rubik's cube,
yeah, you can make that.
There are instructions
for that on the internet.
Getting to interface
with the iPhone,
you can do that as well.
Making it work with Android
would probably
be the next thing coming.
Also, if you want to have
the perfect game of Wii...
[laughs]
I actually met
the inventor last night.
It was really a thrill.
So we recognized
that these guys
really expanded that.
Getting to fetch
your soda cans.
There's some product placement
right here,
but, yeah,
you can do that as well.
There are no limits
to what you can do with this.
But as I said,
I salute the guys out there
who are actually
working with this.
Last year in 2008,
we had the ultimate drop test.
We actually sent some
of our robots up in a balloon
that went to the edge
of the atmosphere.
And one of them actually
got dropped from up there
from 80,000 feet up.
It deployed a parachute,
but actually
came down quite safe.
But it was the ultimate
drop test for us.
Native Chris Anderson
from the Bay Area,
famed from Wired magazine,
actually made a Lego UAV.
He wanted to prove
that he could make a UAV,
Unmanned Aero Vehicle,
for under $1,000,
and he choose our products
as control of the plane,
which is quite amazing.
We also--we've been into space.
Been cleaning up
the space station
together with Russians.
This goes back a while,
but we definitely are going
to go into space again.
So back to my original question.
How many different combinations?
Did you figure out
was in it?
The tally would probably be--
Some of you
might have this number--
102,981,500
different combinations.
But that has actually been
recalculated
by a Danish math professor,
so in essence,
there are 915,103,765.
If any of you guys
had that combination,
please email me.
So enjoy
the rest of the day, guys.
This is it for me.
And thank you.
Keep up the development
with MindStorms.
[applause]